all right he is the former president of
Mexico and he's on our show that's
fantastic you would see him at a trump
rally chanting build that wall his new
book is let's move on beyond fear and
false prophets Vicente Fox
[Applause]
you're a folk hero now yes sir do I call
you mr. president or El Presidente or
amigo amigo okay you really have become
a oh yes you know them they're good
there's no matter let them in yeah you
really become kind of a thorn in Trump's
side when all your stuff is going viral
you're blowing up man what well when it
comes from the heart
yes when it comes when you're offended
like we all 120 million Mexicans sure
and the ones here in this great nation
you have to stand up you have to react
you have to do something although my
visa is almost gone okay so I love this
tweet boy this is the day for dirty
tweets you wrote at real Donald Trump
your mouth is the Fallas [ __ ] in the
world
I say yes you did I have it right here
but you know and this is kind of a trend
because Trump calls Kim Jong on fat and
little man and rocket man and Kim calls
him a dotard and that nut in the
Philippines to tart a he called Obama's
son of a [ __ ] and what's going on with
world leaders that used to be so well
some some take the initiative we orders
react and speaking about this sad very
sad event in Florida these days when you
speak out of the White House this
aggressive violent language when you
discriminate when you are racist right
that's what you get that's what you get
we need harmony we need love we need
happy communities and those concepts
don't come out of his mouth what comes
out of his mouth what you said now let's
turn and the wall you're gonna paint a
one summer roll attack
no me do I have to repeat it now that so
let me ask you about drugs are you
holding No
the violence in Mexico is off the charts
29,000 I think was the figure I read
last year but most of those deaths are
because of a drug war which is fueled by
the United States we are the customers
yes and also probably they get the guns
yeah to do the killing in this country
yes I had to come through Seattle
I was main speaker at this global
conference around cannabis and drugs
cannabis yes sir okay let me tell you
Mexico next May the 30th we're holding a
global cannabis summit because we have
to change precisely that huge problem we
have in Mexico we must move ahead with
legalization unfortunately fortunately
finally Mexico took the step today in
all of Mexico federal government and
local governments will go by this
legalization living behind prohibition
and getting into regulation for medical
use first step but we want to push
forward because we need also legalize
the rest because our problem in Mexico
is and this will be a surprise to you
but the headquarters of crime and
cartels are here in United States and
they are hiring Mexican cartels to bring
in the drug from the south from Colombia
from Venezuela and from elsewhere and I
question myself what happens once that
drug crosses the border what is the DEA
what is the CIA what are they doing if
it's prohibited applied the law but
fortunately many states today here as
long as the profit motive is what it is
when it's illegal I mean we've been
going through this for so many decades
learning the same lesson over and over
again you will never stop drug
trafficking as long as there's this much
money in it now
this state we just legalized it and I
said I happen to know a grower just by
chance no really he told me the price
dropped like overnight from 1600 a pound
to 200 this round of applause
[Applause]
consumption does not increase you
massive amount of money from criminals
into government right through paying
taxes and this is the difference sitting
on your side with chapo guzman or
sitting here with farmers businessmen
that are today running that new industry
this is the parody that we want to
change in Mexico
moving from crying from killings from
all these young kids dying in Mexico
straight into a new industry and this is
what will happen pretty soon in Mexico
and it's happening here for